.
* Dramatische Klänge *
Das Ziel ist, hier drei
3,5-Zimmer-Wohnungen reinzumachen.
Das Gemeinschaftliche hat einen Reiz
und einen grossen Wert fürs Leben.
(Mann) Wir müssen
immer alles auf den Tisch legen,
und zwar früh genug.
Der Stall für die Pferde.
Die Weide vielleicht irgendwie so.
(Frau) Ich bin kein Pferdefan.
(Mann) Die Preise sind gestiegen,
auch für Metall und Holz.
Wir sind jetzt
bei rund 1,5 Mio. Eigenmittel.
Wir sind dort über dem,
was wir mal gesagt haben.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
"Mami, wir haben eine Idee."
"Würdest du auch mitmachen?"
"Überleg es dir mal."
"Wir machen das so und so."
"Wir würden
ein Mehrgenerationenhaus bauen."
"Und du müsstest nie
in ein Altersheim oder so."
"Wenn irgendetwas wäre,
würden wir für dich sorgen."
* Friedliche Klänge *
Da sagte ich zu ihnen:
"Meint ihr das ernst?"
"Wirklich mit mir?"
Sie sagten: "Ja, sonst
würden wir dich nicht fragen."
(Frau) Ja, das müssen wir auch mal
noch wegbringen, das ganze Zeug.
Vier Generationen, ein Ziel:
Aus diesem alten Pferdestall
möchten sie ihr Zuhause bauen.
Drei Wohnungen auf drei Etagen
sind geplant.
In der Mitte
wird Grossmutter Ruth wohnen.
Im Erdgeschoss ihre Tochter,
ebenfalls Ruth.
Und die andere Tochter, Susanna,
wird mit ihrem Mann Pat
in den Dachstock einziehen.
Enkel Philipp ist vor Kurzem
ins Nebenhaus eingezogen,
zusammen mit seiner Frau Jenny.
Die beiden werden in Kürze
zum ersten Mal Eltern.
Hier kannst du sowieso
nicht mehr öffnen.- Das reicht.
Schon gut. Das reicht.
Ein Freund sagte: "Was, du ziehst
mit der Schwiegermutter zusammen?"
Wir lachten. Aber natürlich:
Auf diesem Weg, in diesem Prozess,
in der Auseinandersetzung
mit dem Projekt
waren das zu Beginn
schon Überlegungen.
Wegen der Schwiegermutter,
aber auch wegen der Schwägerin.
Generell -
kann und wird das funktionieren?
Das haben wir uns schon überlegt.
Seit einem halben Jahr wohnen
Philipp und Jenny im Nebenhaus.
Und dann aber
im Massstab von dem hier.
Neben ihrem ersten Kind
haben die beiden 27-Jährigen
noch ein anderes Projekt:
Sie möchten auf dem Grundstück
einen Pferdestall bauen.
Dass die Weide vielleicht so ist,
die kleine.
Ab und zu denke ich schon:
"Ui, schaffen wir das alles?"
Mit einem Stall,
dem Bauprojekt, einem Kind.
Es ist auch schön
mit diesen Ressourcen:
die Leute dort zu haben,
das Grosi, das nebenan wohnt.
Es ist sicher eine Veränderung,
nebeneinander zu wohnen.
Wir müssen dann schon schauen,
wie wir miteinander klarkommen.
Hallo.
- Hoi.- Hallo.
Hoi.
- Hallo.
Einmal pro Woche treffen sich alle
bei Philipp und Jenny zur Bausitzung.
Wir machten uns schon immer
Gedanken über die Zukunft.
Irgendwann kommt die Pension,
auch wenn sie noch weit weg ist.
Als diese Schnapsidee aufkam,
merkten wir,
dass wir alle von den gleichen
Ideen, Träumen, Fantasien sprachen.
Ich mache mich selbstständig
in der Reittherapie.
Darum war es ein grosser Traum, die
Pferde bei mir zu Hause zu haben.
Wegen des Stalls:
Muss der so gross sein?
Zuerst sagten wir dort
oder hier vorne.
(Jenny) Wir haben diskutiert,
wo es schlau platziert ist,
sodass es euch das Zeug
nicht reinwindet.
Auch wenn es hier oben wäre
und unten offen -
der Staub und der Schmutz.
Das kommt dazu,
es ist nicht nur der Geruch.
Wir sagten, wir müssen immer
alles auf den Tisch legen,
und zwar früh genug.
Dass man das einfach
zusammen diskutiert.
Wie kann ein Zusammenleben gelingen
mit so vielen Menschen
mit so unterschiedlichen Bedürfnissen
und finanziellen Mitteln?
Wir haben jetzt noch Eigenkapital
bis zu einem gewissen Punkt.
Wir haben noch die zwei Häuser -
ihres und unseres -,
die wir verkaufen.
Und wir sollten jetzt
die 3,5 Mio. zusammenbringen.
Und ... darum ist es interessant,
wenn wir deins zuerst verkaufen.
Von dir kommt der grosse Teil,
weil du das Haus vor 50 Jahren
für wenig Geld gekauft hast.
Das Projekt
kostet insgesamt 3,5 Mio. Fr.
Es umfasst vier Wohneinheiten
plus den neuen Pferdestall.
Jede Person bringt unterschiedlich
viel Eigenkapital mit,
aber besitzen
werden alle gleich viel.
Und sie haben auch
das gleiche Mitspracherecht.
Wir beginnen ja unten mit Bauen.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Soll ich schon die Suppe schöpfen?
Pfeffer hat es jetzt.
Prost.- Cheers.
- Prost.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Nach zwei Jahren Planung:
der Baustart.
Eine Architektin gibt es nicht,
eine Baufirma
realisiert den kompletten Bau.
Die Auflagen des Kanton Thurgaus
sind streng.
Der Charakter der Scheune
darf nicht verändert werden.
Ich finde es toll, dass ich das
überhaupt noch mitmachen kann.
Ja.
Die Familie
möchte beim Bauen mit anpacken.
Beim Balkon ...
Du hast gesagt,
wir können beim Holz mithelfen.
Wie sieht unsere Arbeit aus?
- Z.T. gibt es sichtbare Träger.
Die bürsten wir immer -
fasen und bürsten.
Diese Arbeit könnt ihr gut machen.
Dann die Innenwände dämmen.
Der Sinn des Mitarbeitens:
Wir wollten reinwachsen
und nicht einfach am Schluss
etwas Bestehendes übernehmen.
Wir machten das bewusst,
um uns zu finden.
Wir hofften auch,
Kosten einsparen zu können.
Und die Zeit - wir hatten von Anfang
an eine ehrgeizige Zeitschiene.
Wenn wir am Wochenende unterstützen
können, gewinnen wir etwas.
Hier hat es noch Süssmost von
unseren Bäumen, wenn jemand möchte.
Und das sind süsse Muffins
mit Schokolade.
Super, vielen Dank.
- Gern geschehen.
Susanna und ihre Schwester Ruth
wollten schon vor Jahrzehnten
gemeinsam
ein Hausprojekt realisieren.
Damals waren sie
noch mit anderen Männern liiert.
Jetzt wollen sie
ihren Traum realisieren:
zusammen im Grünen wohnen
und auch arbeiten -
in ihrer eigenen Akkupressurpraxis.
Es ist das, was wir suchen.
Ich mag es, wenn ich aus dem Haus
gehen kann und es dort Felder hat,
wo ich spazieren kann.
Das ist für mich Freiheit.
Ja.
Das Problem ist einfach, wenn ich
mal nicht mehr Auto fahren kann.
Einfach wenn etwas ist - aber ja.
- Es ist ja immer jemand da.
Dann muss man halt wieder planen -
ich habe schon mal so gewohnt,
dass ich einmal die Woche
einkaufen gehen musste
und es sonst nichts hatte.
- Mhm.
Zur nächsten Einkaufsmöglichkeit
ist es zu Fuss eine halbe Stunde,
zur nächsten Post 1 Std.
Auch das Projekt nebenan
nimmt Form an:
Der kleine Lian ist da.
Nimmst du ihn draussen in die Trage?
- Ja.
Oder mit dem Wagen?
- Nein, in die Trage.
Ich finde es megacool,
dass er schon seinen Charakter hat.
Es ist so süss -
auch, wie er einfordert.
Er weiss schon ziemlich,
was er will.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das hat er von uns beiden.
Wenn er Hunger hat,
möchte er  j e t z t  essen.
(Leise) So. Zum Mami.
In den kommenden Monaten wird Tag für
Tag emsig an ihrem Traum gearbeitet.
Sämtliche Wände werden ersetzt und
die Balken der drei Etagen montiert.
Schieben.
* Friedlich dynamische Musik *
(Pat) Die Balken sind gesetzt.
- (Philipp) Ja.
Das sind deine Fenster.
- Schön.
Gehen wir auch etwas arbeiten?
- Ja.
Jedes Wochenende
macht die Familie Arbeiten,
die sonst Lehrlinge erledigen.
Irgendein Vogel,
der hier drin verendet ist.
Er ist irgendwie eingeklemmt
zwischen dem Metall und dem Holz.
Lass ihn mal,
ich nehme ihn später runter.
Philipp hat eine enge Bindung
zu seiner Herkunftsfamilie.
Tür an Tür mit ihnen zu leben -
für ihn kein Problem.
Noch sind alle gesundheitlich fit,
doch wie wird es in Zukunft sein,
wenn Grossmutter,
Mutter, Tante und Onkel
einmal nicht mehr
so selbstständig sind?
Ich glaube, in der Familie
ist man sowieso füreinander da,
wenn man älter wird -
ob man beieinander wohnt oder nicht.
Man weiss nie,
was in 10 oder 15 Jahren ist.
Wenn wir mit der Angst
in dieses Projekt gegangen wären:
"Boah, was passiert, wenn
jemand stirbt, wenn zwei sterben,
wenn jemand schwer krank wird,
nicht mehr hier leben kann?",
dann hätten wir das Projekt nicht in
dieser Leichtigkeit machen können.
Philipp möchte
für seine Familie da sein,
auch für seinen
angeheirateten Onkel Pat.
Sie kommen schon.
Sie sind etwas widerspenstig,
aber ...- Ja.
Aber besser, wenn es kurz ist.
- Viel besser.
Er hat schon eine Rolle in
meinem Leben, die mir geholfen hat.
Die Männerrolle auch,
das Männerbild in meiner Familie.
Ich hatte
mit meiner Schwester und der Mutter
einfach zwei Frauen im Haus.
Darum hat das schon geholfen.
Ich bin irgendwie
in die Rolle reingerutscht ...
Keine Ahnung, Vaterersatz, Götti...
...ersatz, Onkel.
Und ja.
Von daher ist es völlig natürlich,
dass wir zusammengehören.
Um mögliche Erbstreitigkeiten zu ver-
hindern, wird auch Philipps Schwester
testamentarisch gleichberechtigt wie
Philipp in dieses Projekt einbezogen.
Es geht nicht gut.
Aber ich finde,
man hilft einfach, wo man kann.
Ruth Senior steht mit 77 Jahren
noch einmal vor einem neuen Lebens-
abschnitt - mit gemischten Gefühlen.
Jetzt ist einfach, ja ...
Jetzt verkaufen wir dann diese
Häuser, die Leute kommen schauen.
Das ist auch ein bisschen ...
Wir wissen es ja,
das ist jetzt einfach so.
Ja.
* Dynamische Musik *
Fast jedes Wochenende arbeitet
die Familie auf der Baustelle.
Susanna und Pat können es
kaum erwarten, hier einzuziehen.
Was ich mir erhoffe:
die Ruhe, die ich hier oben finden
werde, und auch die Kompaktheit -
die Wohnung ist gross,
aber sie ist auf einem Stock.
Ich habe dann
nicht mehr drei Stockwerke.
Darauf freue ich mich.
(Pat) Alles gut? - Ja.
- Hoi, Schätzchen.
Wo ist er? Ah, hier. Hoi.
Der schläft immer.
- Schön wär's!
(Lachend) Ausser in der Nacht.
Wenn ich ihn sehe, schläft er immer.
(Pat) Danke für den Kaffee.
- (Philipp) Das ist lieb.
Hier hinten
entsteht dann der Pferdestall.
Ja, genau. So breit wird es ungefähr
und so lang.
Wenn sie dann da sind,
wird der Bezug auch nochmals anders.
Jetzt ist es einfach:
"Ui, die Pferde,
die machen viel Mist und so,
wie macht man was?"
Es ist alles ein Sich-Herantasten.
Dann kommt es sehr gut.
Nicht alle teilen den Traum,
dass hier auch Pferde leben sollen.
Den Duft der Tiere
haben sie gerade erst
mit einer Spezialimprägnierung
aus dem Holz verbannt.
Stinken die Balken nicht
von den Pferden?
Haben sie etwas eingesprayt?
- Ja.
Man riecht gar nichts.
Ich wollte als Kind immer
reiten lernen, durfte aber nicht.
Auf dem Weg von der Schule ging ich
immer beim Pferdestall vorbei.
Ich musste mir dann zu Hause
immer anhören, dass ich stinke.
Ich bin kein Pferdefan.
Das ist Jennys Ding, aber ich ...
Aber das muss jeder selbst wissen.
Aber ich habe damit nichts am Hut.
Wie?
- Die Leiter ...
* Gemütliche Musik *
Rickenbach Sulz
in der Nähe von Winterthur.
* Sie füllt etwas mit Wasser. *
Der hier
bekommt jeweils Wachsblumen.
Ich war jetzt 46 Jahre
in diesem Haus.
Oder jetzt immer noch.
Es ist einfach mein Zuhause.
Ruth, inzwischen Urgrossmutter,
hat Zweifel,
ob es richtig war,
den Schritt zu wagen.
Dort oben ist man einfach
ein bisschen weg, abseits.
Das ist das.
Gut, sie haben versprochen, dass
sie mich irgendwo hinbringen würden,
aber es ist trotzdem nicht dasselbe.
Ich kann dann nicht mehr
einfach abhauen, wenn ich will.
Ja. Es ist einfach so.
Das hier ist noch mein Schlafzimmer.
Oder unseres.
Das kommt jetzt weg.
Ich bekomme ein neues.
Alles, das ganze Schlafzimmer
wird neu.
In diesem Haus
hat sie ihre Kinder grossgezogen,
zusammen mit ihrem Mann Jakob.
Seit seinem Tod vor fünf Jahren
belastete sie das Haus
samt grossem Garten mehr und mehr.
* Leise, sanfte Musik.
Ein Rasenmäher brummt. *
Dass man immer
alles selber entscheiden muss.
Das ist schon nicht so einfach.
Und ich bin auch keine 20 mehr.
Das kommt dann eben noch dazu.
Man macht es nicht mehr so einfach.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass irgendetwas anders werden muss.
* Sanfte Musik *
Seit einem halben Jahr wird auf
der Baustelle Tag für Tag gearbeitet.
Heute geht es um ein wichtiges
Element des Hauses: den Lift.
Dieser ist für sie
nicht nur essenziell im Alter -
auch für die zukünftige Praxis
von Susanna und Ruth.
Ich habe
in der Standardausführung angeboten.
Man kann z.B. die Türen
auch automatisiert haben.
Damit kann man den Preis
in die Höhe treiben.
Nein, wir müssten ihn
runtertreiben, nicht hoch.
Gut, dann wäre wahrscheinlich
die Option, wie sie im Angebot ist,
mit der Standardausführung,
auch mit der Rückwand ...
Das spielt keine grosse Rolle, oder?
Das macht Sinn, oder?
Pat trägt die Verantwortung
für die Finanzen.
Der 56-Jährige
hat schon einmal gebaut.
Er verfügt über die nötige Erfahrung.
... ebenerdig?
- Genau.
Wir haben ein gewisses Risiko
auf uns genommen.
Wir sind nicht all in gegangen,
haben nicht den letzten Franken
zusammengekratzt.
Aber wir mussten schon Reserven
anzapfen, die wir nicht wollten.
Die Gelder der 3. Säule
wollte ich nicht unbedingt nehmen.
Aber das ... geht halt nicht anders.
Die Familie ist im engen Austausch
mit der Holzbaufirma,
wie weit der Bau fortgeschritten ist
und welche Arbeiten
sie selbst erledigen können.
Schau mal die Striemen,
die müssen möglichst weg sein.
Wir lernen.
Genau, Qualitätskontrolle
nennt man das.
Nein, die sind gut aussortiert.
Wir haben schon
viel Schlimmeres gesehen.
Mit Flecken.
Das Schöne ist: Was die Kundschaft
selbst macht, gefällt ihr immer.
Sie sind schneller zufrieden.
Da bin ich nicht sicher.
Wir sind relativ selbstkritisch.
Aber man sagt viel schneller,
die Täfer seien nicht schön,
die müssen runter, aber wenn man sie
selbst gelaugt hat, bleiben sie.
Es braucht einfach
wahnsinnig viel Zeit.
Dort sind wir momentan alle
sehr gefordert -
wir haben keine Freizeit.
Es ist halt einfach intensiv.
Aber schön. Es ist ja schön.
Aber es ist sehr streng.
Ich hoffe, dass sie irgendwann
die Treppe hier hinstellen,
damit auch die Grossmutter
mal hochkommen kann.
Parallel zu ihrem Einsatz hier
sind sie berufstätig.
Ruth Junior und Susanna
als Akupressurtherapeutinnen.
Wir müssen anders rausklettern.
Pat als Leiter Innendienst.
Nein, so.
- Aha. Auch gut.
Jenny ist Sozialpädagogin
und Reittherapeutin,
während Philipp
in der IT-Branche arbeitet.
Seit knapp einem Jahr lebt er
mit seiner Familie im Nebenhaus,
umgeben von Natur.
Die Fahrt nach Winterthur,
in seine alte Heimat,
dauert 30 Min. mit dem Auto.
Das ist eine Einbusse,
die ich für mich, für uns alle
in Kauf nehmen musste,
dass wir abgeschiedener sind.
Das ist schon gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Man nimmt für alles das Auto.
Unsere Freunde müssen sich auch
daran gewöhnen, zu uns rauszufahren.
Das ist vielleicht eher
ein Minuspunkt an diesem Objekt.
Aber man nimmt es in Kauf für alles
andere Schöne, das man dafür hat.
In Zürich suchen sie
nach passenden Küchen.
Wenn sie sich einig sind und alle die
gleiche wählen, wird es günstiger.
(Mann) Ihr könnt mal
die Hand hinhalten.
Du musst dich auch wohlfühlen
mit dem Neumodischen.
Wir sprechen von 600 Kubik.
Den finde ich schön.
Vielleicht muss man das versuchen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das sind blöde Knöpfe,
wenn du das andere elegant
mit Touchscreen haben kannst.
Ich finde es nicht schlimm.
Da kannst du das so lösen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist nicht
mehr zeitgemäss.- Moderne Knöpfe.
Jetzt haben wir etwas zum Brüten.
(Lachend) Ja.
Im Katalog
sind alle Produktpreise hinterlegt.
Sie können mal schauen,
was das in etwa kostet.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Danke.
* Schwingende Musik *
Ich mag es,
wenn es so läuft, wie ich es will.
Und ich sage den Leuten manchmal -
das kommt nicht immer gut an -,
wie ich es will.
Manchmal gibt es Diskussionen,
wenn es heisst:
"Ja, ja. Aber jetzt bremsen wir mal
und schauen erst mal."
Das ist so, ja.
Der Elektriker war auch schon hier.
Es ist alles reingezogen.
In diesem Bereich
wird die Küche sein.
Ja, es ist dann schräg da hinten.
Ich werde hier dann
knapp stehen können. Das geht schon.
Wie das dann genau aussieht, wissen
wir noch nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Wir sind hier oben.
Wie jeden Dienstag
treffen sie sich zur Baubesprechung.
Überraschung.
Hoi, Ruth.
- Hoi, Mathias.
Die Preise sind gestiegen,
natürlich auch für Metall und Holz.
Und dann zogen alle Hersteller -
wie immer - sofort nach.
Auch Materialien ohne Holz
oder Metall sind teurer geworden.
Merkwürdigerweise.
Wir können viel optimieren,
wenn wir nichts Extravagantes
in die Badezimmer und die Küchen
einbauen,
wenn wir dort
den Finger drauf halten.
Und da wir auch viel selber machen,
denke ich, dass es gut kommt.
Ich führe ja Buchhaltung,
schaue, wo wir stehen,
und versuche es abzuschätzen,
aber es ist schwierig.
* Hüpfende Klaviermelodie *
Ich glaube, da brauchen wir
noch zwei oder drei Ladungen.
Oberhalb der Firstspitze abstellen.
Je länger die Bauzeit,
desto mehr werden
die finanziellen Mittel ein Thema.
Die Familie
steht vor vielen Entscheidungen:
Wo können sie sparen, wo nicht?
Das wäre sein Standard, oder?
- (Zögerlich) Nein.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das der Standard ist.
Aber das würde er
als günstigere Variante machen.
Es ist wie immer eine Preisfrage.
Wir müssen uns überlegen,
ob es uns das wert ist,
den teureren Boden reinzumachen,
oder ob uns die günstigere Variante
reicht und gut genug ist.
Also, ich gehe
über die günstigere Variante.
* Dumpfes Poltern *
Jetzt hüpfst du?
- Ja, also ich stampfe leicht.
Jetzt ist er
auf dieser Platte drauf.
Jetzt geht er auf dem anderen,
dem besseren.
Ist das ein Unterschied?
Ja.
- Ja.
Wir müssen tun, was wir können,
um die Geräusche zu minimieren.
Aber er muss sagen, was es kostet,
den Mehrpreis nennen.- Gut, danke.
Pat informiert die Familie über
den aktuellen Stand der Finanzen.
Ihr wisst, ich führe eine Liste mit
den Rechnungen von den Handwerkern,
um einigermassen
den Überblick zu behalten.
Der Kostenvoranschlag
war ohne Mehrwertsteuer.
Wir merkten nicht, dass dort
noch 7,7 % obendrauf kommen.
Damit wir es
wirklich vergleichen können,
habe ich hier
die Mehrwertsteuer draufgerechnet.
Dieses Werte sind alle 7,7 % höher.
Es war ein offensichtlicher Fehler.
Es sind 7,7 %.
Wenn man das hochrechnet
auf diesen Betrag ...
Es hat mich also schon
einen Moment geärgert.
Aber im Nachhinein ... ja.
Es ist, wie es ist.
Beim Sanitär haben wir
einen Schuh voll rausgezogen.
Es gab einen Fehler
in der Kalkulation.
Dort ist es ein grosser Posten,
etwa 50'000.
(Philipp) Das ist fies, ja.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn:
Wir sind über dem,
was wir mal gesagt haben.
Wir sind
bei rund 1,5 Mio. Eigenmittel.
Ich wollte bis am Dienstag
Bescheid wissen
über die allfälligen
Mehrkosten für die Böden.
Was noch fehlt: Der Stall
ist noch nicht eingerechnet.
Dort kommt noch etwas,
wir hatten aber nie eine Offerte.
Oder vielleicht sind die Werte
nicht bis zu mir gekommen.
Aber das können nicht
Hunderttausende sein.
Wir sollten zwei Dinge tun:
uns überlegen,
wo wir allenfalls noch sparen
können, das erscheint mir schwierig.
Da müssen wir
auf die restlichen Offerten warten.
Das andere ist, damit können wir
uns auseinandersetzen:
Wo haben wir noch Eigenmittel,
die wir einschiessen können?
(Philipp) Für mich ...
Ich möchte das nicht.
Spontan ist niemand bereit, mehr Geld
zu geben. Auch Ruth Senior nicht.
Sie hat sich extra Geld aufgespart,
um sich neue Möbel zu kaufen.
Das will sie so beibehalten.
* Feine Klaviermelodie *
* Fräsgeräusche *
In vier Monaten ist Einzugstermin.
Obwohl das Geld knapp ist, müssen sie
weitere kostspielige Entscheidungen
treffen.
Ich habe diese Woche
sehr an euer Geld gedacht.
Ich habe Bestellungen
für 60'000 Fr. gemacht.
(Philipp) Böden, Türen und so?
Boden, Türen und - was war noch -
die Isolation.
Beim Bodenaufbau
gibt es jetzt den teureren.
Wir hoffen, dass das
schlussendlich auch etwas nützt.
(Mann) Pablo?
Kann ich kurz den Geissfuss haben?
* Türklingel *
Hoi, Marina.
- Hoi, Ruth.
Machen wir etwas im Garten?
- Ja.
Hier drüben,
der mit den violetten Beeren.
Dieser Strauch heisst Liebesperlen.
So?
- Ja.
Marina Kühnis
hat das Haus von Ruth gekauft.
Sie ist in der Nachbarschaft
aufgewachsen.
Eben, diese hier ...
Ich glaube, es musste so sein,
dass wir zwei uns gefunden haben.
Es ist einfacher für mich,
loszulassen,
weil ich weiss, dass es ihr gefällt
und sie es schätzt.
Sie hat mir
einen lieben Brief geschrieben.
Und der Rhabarber ...
- Rhabarberwähe.
Ja, nicht?
Das hatte ich früher
bei meiner Omi ...
Marina
zieht mit ihrer Familie hier ein.
Einfach zusammenlegen und zudecken.
In erster Linie möchte ich es
mal so lassen und leben.
Weil Ruth alles gut gepflegt
und Sorge getragen hat dazu,
habe ich, als ich es gesehen habe,
gesagt, das wäre mein Traum.
Hast du gesehen? Ich hatte nochmals
angesät. Jetzt ist der Rasen schön.
Es ist immer etwas Neues, nicht?
- Ja, es ist immer etwas Neues.
Aber manchmal denke ich auch,
Stillstand ist auch nicht gut.
Wenn man nur herumsitzt und
nichts mehr tut, das ist nicht gut.
Der Verkauf der Häuser von
Ruth Senior und von Pat und Susanna
ist sehr gut gelaufen.
Finanziell sind sie nun
besser gestellt als erhofft.
Da?
- Ja.
Während der Pandemie gab es
eine richtig grosse Nachfrage -
die Leute wollten aufs Land,
aus der Wohnung raus in ein Haus.
Die Hypothekarzinsen waren damals
auf dem absoluten Tiefpunkt,
also konnten sich
viele Leute überlegen,
ob sie etwas Eigenes kaufen können.
Davon
konnten wir etwas profitieren.
Wir konnten unsere Häuser
eigentlich ...
... teurer verkaufen
als ursprünglich gedacht.
Das hilft uns.
* Gemütliche Klavierklänge *
Der Bau steht in der Endphase.
In zwei Monaten plant die Familie
hier einzuziehen und zu arbeiten.
Dafür bereiten sie sich
bei Susanna zu Hause vor.
Susanna, Jenny und Ruth Junior wollen
das Geschäft gemeinsam aufziehen.
Der Name: MUT - Mensch und Tier.
Dafür entwerfen sie ein Logo.
Was habt ihr abgemacht?
Du machst ganz dunkel?
Hinten halt.
Und die Blätter werden heller.
Der Buchstabe - ich weiss gar nicht.
Wir hatten alle
eine Art den gleichen Traum.
Wenn man so ein Ziel hat,
kann man Energien freisetzen,
dass du denkst: Boah.
Du warst jetzt natürlich
sehr absorbiert mit Lian
und konntest dadurch
gar nicht so teilnehmen.
Jetzt ist höchste Zeit, dass du dich
auch wieder entfalten kannst.
Ja.
Ich glaube,
wenn du das als Logo nimmst
und oben den Schriftzug,
sieht das toll aus.
Ja. Das ist gut.
- Zum Glück, ja.
- Cool.
* Emsige, gezupfte Klänge *
Los, los, los!
Um rechtzeitig fertig zu werden,
legen die Bauarbeiter
Extraschichten ein.
Nachher kannst du
nichts mehr korrigieren.
Es reicht noch nicht.
Nachmessen.
Wahrscheinlich die Ecke hochnehmen.
Hier hinten kann ich auch
fertig montieren, oder? - Ja.
Geht das? Nein!
Nächstes Mal müssen wir
mehr Bretter bereitmachen.
Und auch der Pferdestall
nimmt Formen an.
Wir haben den Pferdestall
von einem Bauarbeiter bekommen.
Bzw. war es vorher eine Scheune,
die dort in Familienbesitz war.
Es machte preislich viel aus,
um die 10'000 Fr.
Und auch ressourcentechnisch,
weil wir Holz verwenden konnten,
das schon da war. Das ist auch cool.
Hoi, Sylvia.
- Hoi.
Fünf Tage bis zum Einzug.
- Du kennst die Leistung noch nicht.
Um weitere Kosten zu sparen, helfen
Freundinnen bei der Grundreinigung.
Zuerst wollen diese aber
das neue Zuhause bestaunen.
Sieht cool aus. Wirklich schön.
... guten Architekten gehabt ...
- Da steht er.
In der Küche haben sie sich
für Pats Favoriten entschieden:
ein Kochfeld mit Touchscreen.
- Es hat sich viel verändert.
In drei Wochen haben sie die Küche
aufgebaut, das Badezimmer - alles.
Ich weiss nicht, wie das geht.
Sie sind echt Künstler.
Am 18. Januar in meiner Stube.
Siehst du?
- Krass.- Ja, nicht?
Vor drei Jahren haben sie
mit der Planung angefangen,
unzählige Stunden investiert.
Nun stehen sie im fast fertigen Haus.
Ein emotionaler Moment.
Dafür haben wir Taschentücher.
* Friedlich perlende Klänge *
So schön.
Beim Lift haben sie sich für
die günstigere Variante entschieden.
Hier hat es ein Nottelefon.
Und wenn man hier drauflehnt,
stoppt er.
Eine Hebebühne direkt im Schacht.
Diese fährt langsamer
als ein gewöhnlicher Lift.
Er ist ganz erstarrt
wegen des vielen Zeugs.
Es ist alles etwas viel, was?
Irgendwie haben wir doch gerade noch
gesagt: "Es geht noch ein Jahr."
Und jetzt ist es einfach nächste
Woche fertig und sie ziehen ein.
Es ist unglaublich.
Ein Jahr Bauzeit ist vorbei.
Jetzt können sie endlich einziehen.
Die kommen in die Praxis?
- Ja.
Ja, gerne. Gleich geradeaus.
Diese Decken kann man nehmen.
Aha.
- Ja.
Hier musst du nicht immer hin,
nur an die Spieleschublade.
Wir könnten ihm noch etwas geben.
- Ich glaube, es ist gut so.
Noch den Tisch dort dazwischen
und mal den Abstand anschauen.
Während im Dachgeschoss noch über
die Möbelpositionen diskutiert wird,
sieht es eine Etage tiefer
bei Urgrossmutter Ruth
schon wohnlicher aus.
Ein neues Schlafzimmer
habe ich mir gekauft.
Das muss ich dann
auch noch schöner machen.
Jetzt liegt noch alles lose rum.
Vorher hatte ich noch
das Doppelbett.
Das habe ich
Philipp und Jenny geschenkt.
Das ist jetzt wirklich
ein Neuanfang.
Ja. Dort vorne
kommt dann der Pferdestall hin.
Wir dachten zuerst,
er sei weiter oben.
Aber nach Plan
stimmt das ganz genau.
Aber wir wissen halt nicht,
wie es rauskommt. Mal schauen.
Aber ich hoffe, es wird gut.
* Klimpernde Keyboardklänge *
- Musik. Schau nochmals.
Ja. Fest tanzen.
* Wiehern *
Zwei Monate später
ziehen die letzten Bewohner ein.
Ja, fein. Gut.
Wo willst du schauen?
(Beruhigend) Super. Ja.
So ein kuscheliges Bett für dich.
Ja.
* Jenny lacht. *
Äpfeln ist immer gut,
dann sind sie mehr oder weniger
entspannt, können loslassen.
Wie bei uns. Das finde ich super.
* Treibende Musik *
Damit geht für Jenny
ihr Mädchentraum in Erfüllung.
Der Kleine.
Sie ist überzeugt, dass die Bedenken
von Grosi Ruth umsonst waren.
Ist er nett?
Sie sieht ihn vielleicht ja
sogar vom Balkon.
Dann sieht sie den Kleinen.
Das Kleine
hat einfach etwas Niedliches,
und er ist einfach  s o  klein
und süss ...
Ein Jöö-Effekt,
den er bei jedem auslöst.
Jetzt haben wir das geschafft,
auf was wir hingearbeitet haben
die letzten etwa drei Jahre.
Ja, insgesamt schon.- Es ist
schon krass, jetzt sind wir hier.
Jetzt kann es ruhig werden,
sich einpendeln und ...
Das ist das Ziel, ja.
Oder die Hoffnung.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Drei Monate später.
Ruth Junior und Susanna haben
ihre Akkupressurpraxis eröffnet.
Die meisten Patient/-innen
seien bereit,
den weiteren Weg auf sich zu nehmen.
Und Jenny
hat mit der Reittherapie angefangen.
Pasco oder Zedi?
Sanft. Bürsten, so.
Das ist der Schlauch.
Ruth Senior geniesst die Ruhe
nach dem Umzugsstress.
* Wiehern *
Meinstens, wenn so schönes Wetter
ist, frühstücke ich hier draussen.
Dann sind die Pferde auf der Weide,
das ist schön anzuschauen.
Es ist nicht so schlimm.
Ich war zwar noch nie ...
Ich sehe sie einfach von Weitem.
Ich habe Respekt vor diesen Tieren.
* Wiehern *
Sie sind im Alltag angekommen.
Die finale Schlussrechnung hingegen
ist noch nicht gemacht.
Mit den Kosten ist es so:
Wir sind etwa 300'000 über Budget.
Einerseits wussten wir,
dass das so kommt,
weil wir Posten reingenommen haben,
die am Anfang nicht drin waren,
z.B. die Öfen.
Andererseits waren gewisse Dinge
in der Kalkulation
zu wenig gut berechnet.
Es wurde teurer.
Ja, es ist ...
Wir hatten Reserven drin,
nicht ganz so viele.
Wir mussten noch über die Bücher
und gewisse Gelder
aus der 3. Säule nehmen,
was wir nicht wollten.
Aber am Schluss geht's auf.
Heute Mittag trifft sich die Familie
bei Ruth Junior im Erdgeschoss
zum gemeinsamen Mittagessen.
Es ist etwas haarig hier.
Wir versuchen momentan,
alle zwei bis drei Wochen
ein offizielles Zusammensitzen
zu haben,
wo wir Dinge besprechen,
die noch offen sind,
die in der Gemeinschaft vorkommen.
Themen, die wir vor einem Jahr
schon angefangen
und noch nicht abgeschlossen haben,
z.B., wie wir
die Testamente genau regeln.
Wir bleiben dran, und dieser
Austausch ist auch sehr wichtig.
Falls es mal einen Konflikt gibt,
können wir den auf den Tisch brin-
gen, thematisieren und weitermachen.
(Alle) En Guete!
Oh, oh, oh.
- Ein grosser Biss?
* Missmutige Laute *
Doch nicht? Nein.
Hätte mich auch gewundert. Oliven
haben einen speziellen Geschmack.
Was megacool ist:
Es sind alle hier
und Lian hat eine sehr starke
Bindung zu allen, das ist schön.
Sobald Philipps Grosi kommt,
rennt er zu ihr und freut sich.
Einen solchen Bezug hatte ich
gar nicht zu meinen Urgrosseltern.
Das ist ein grosses Geschenk.
* Sie sprechen leise. *
Der ganze Stress und der Druck,
die wir hatten  -
wir waren
auf einem hohen Stresslevel.
Dass wir mal runterfahren
und ankommen können.
Man ist voll im Projekt drin
und es läuft die ganze Zeit.
Man merkt nicht, wie schön es ist,
was wir erreicht haben,
um hier zu sein.
Ich wünsche mir,
dass ich gesund bleibe,
dass ich noch lange hier sein darf.
Ja.
* Lian ruft. *
Und dass wir es schön haben.
* Friedliche Musik *
Eine Last, die jetzt abfällt.
- Ja, das ist es.
Dass es so gelungen ist.
Niemand konnte wissen,
wie es am Schluss ...
Man fängt mal etwas an,
und es ist alles nur gut geworden.
Ja.
- Ja.
Jetzt freuen wir uns,
wenn der Garten noch gemacht ist.
Ja, der hat noch Potenzial ...
... dass es besser wird.
Die Vorzeichen stehen gut, den ge-
meinsamen Weg glücklich fortzusetzen.
Mit der Bereitschaft, Abstand und
Nähe immer wieder neu zu justieren.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Martina Riedi - 2023